CARTER MORGAN: Welcome to Cloud
Security Basics, a new series
where we explain the
ins and outs of securing
your application
on Google Cloud.
Sound fun?
Then stick around
because in this episode,
you'll learn about Google
Cloud's physical defense
of their data
centers and hardware.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRAD ACTOR: Hello,
cloud detective.
You may have solved
last week's question
about securing customers' data.
But what about securing
the data centers
and other physical hardware
that runs your software?
You may have everything else
and your ecosystem is secure.
What will you do about machine
or supply chain-related issues?
How can you be sure the
physical devices are
being properly secured?
Or what if some bad
actor plants malware
on your precious machines?
What can you do to stop that?
For your sake, I hope you know
the answer to my question.
CARTER MORGAN: OK,
here's what we know.
Physical security has
two components-- securing
the physical servers and the
data centers that data lives on
and ensuring the physical
and virtual systems
that applications
rely on are secure,
like with a route of trust.
If the physical devices
aren't being properly secured,
someone could steal a
machine with your data
on it, plant malware
on it, or otherwise
tamper with the
machines, compromising
the security of anyone
who uses those instances.
Luckily, Google Cloud provides
a lot of tools and services
to protect its users.
When it comes to securing the
physical premises and hardware,
access to Google data
centers is limited
to a small number of specially
qualified Google employees.
Less than 1% of
googlers will ever
set foot into a data center.
Access to the data
center floor is
only possible via
security corridor, which
implements multi-factor access
controls using security badges
and biometrics.
When it comes to securing the
virtualization and hardware
component software
runs on, Google
has designed a lot of custom
tooling to protect its users.
Google data centers
have thousands
of server machines connected
to a local network providing
an initial layer of security.
Both the server boards and
the networking equipment
are custom designed by Google to
adhere to their tough security
requirements.
And Google's custom-designed
Titan hardware security chip
can be deployed on both
servers and peripherals,
allowing Google to identify
and authenticate devices
at the hardware level.
With security like
that, you can be
sure the hardware your
software runs on is secure.
Let's see a few
specific examples
of how Google
secures the platform.
So how does Google Cloud
secure the data centers
and other physical hardware
that runs your software?
Hmm, first, let's talk about
securing the data center.
On top of the technologies,
like biometric identification,
metal detectors, camera,
physical barriers,
and laser-based
intrusion detection,
as you get closer to
the data center floor,
security measures also increase.
Access to the data
center floor is
only possible via
security corridor, which
implements multi-factor access
controls using security badges
and biometrics.
Plus, data centers are
routinely patrolled
by experienced
security guards who
have undergone rigorous
background checks and training.
So that's the physical
defense of data centers.
But what about virtual and
real hardware security?
Well, there's a Titan chip.
Titan is a secure
low-power microcontroller
designed with Google security,
requirements, and hardware
scenarios in mind.
Titan provides a hardware
based route of trust
that establishes a strong
identity for a machine, which
enables Google to make
important security decisions
and validate the
"health" of the system.
Titan offers integrity
verification of firmware
and software components.
The system's strong
identity ensures
that there's a true audit
trail of any changes done
to the system.
Tamper-evident
logging capabilities
help identify actions performed
by an insider with root access.
All of these features
come together
to allow Google to securely
run operating systems that
have been verified
and authenticated.
And then there's KVM or the
kernel-based virtual machine
that Google uses as the
foundations of Google Compute
Engine and Google
Kubernetes engine.
KVM is an open source
virtualization technology
built right into Linux
and lets you turn Linux
into a hypervisor that allows
one host machine to run
multiple isolated VMs.
Plus, Google invests in
additional security hardening
and protections based on
his research and testing
experiences.
For example, the
Google Security team
performs thorough
code reviews each time
they adopt a new feature
or version of KVM
and uses an extensive set
of proprietary fuzzing tools
for KVM to further test it.
Google removes unused KVM
components, like legacy mouse
drivers, to reduce
the attack service
for potential
adversaries to exploit.
And instead of using the more
complex QEMU emulator built
into KVM, Google wrote
its own user space
virtual machine monitor and
hardware emulator, which
is simpler, better tested,
and offer significant security
advantages.
These are just a
few of the steps
Google's taken to heart
in KVM for its services
and its customers.
So we see how Google uses
hardware, virtualization,
and physical security
to protect its tooling.
Mm, and I see how to answer
Brad Actor's question.
BRAD ACTOR: I see you've
been busy, Detective.
Somehow you answered
my little question.
How do you secure the platform?
The data center's
another physical hardware
that runs your software.
I see you found the
crux of the argument.
Google's commitment to
security first design
keeps the platform secure.
Google Cloud manages security
throughout the data lifecycle
from the data center to
the device using a range
of technologies and approaches.
Very good-- very good.
You seem to have the basics
covered, but be wary.
I'll return with questions
about forensic and preventative
actions.
You've been warned, Detective.
Ha, ha, ha.
CARTER MORGAN: So
there you have it.
That's another episode
of Cloud Security Basics.
If you want to take a deeper
dive in how Google secures
its data centers and
physical hardware,
check out the article linked
in the description below.
Next, we're going
to start looking
at some preventative
and forensic actions.
Stay tuned because when it
comes to cloud security,
you can't let bad actors win.
[MUSIC PLAYING]